اذا هو تحول واضح وسريعه في سياسه اليابان
العسكريه ومسائل التسليح والامن القومي
هذا تحول بدا نهايه العام الماضي ففي
الثاني والعشرين من شهر اكتوبر وقعت
اليابان مع استراليا اتفاق نمليا يقضي
بتبادل المعلومات الى استخباراتيه الحساسه
وتعزيز التعاون العسكري بموجب الاتفاق
تجري اليابان واستراليا تدريبات عسكريه
مشتركه شمالي استراليا في منتصف شهر
ديسمبر الماضي اعلنت اليابان استراتيجيه
دفاعيه جديده تقضي بزياده الانفاق الدفاع
الى اثنين في المئه من الاقتصاد بحلول
تتضمنوا تخصيصه 320 مليار دولار لتقويه
القدرات العسكريه كما قررت اليابان توحيد
القياده العسكريه وزياده مدى صواريخها هذه
الاستراتيجيه اليابانيه الجديده جعلت من
ميزانيها العسكريه ثالثه اكبر الميزانيه
عسكريه في العالم بعد الولايات المتح كده
وصينا كما انها تعتبر اكبر مراجعه لسياسه
الدفاعيه اليابانيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في الحادي عشر من يناير وقع طوكيو
مع لندن اتفاقيه دفاعيه تسمح للبلدين بنشر
قوات على اراضي كل منهما